Blockhead bunnies and disembodied cat
unicorn princesses.
It's episode 40 of IMG!
You've gotta be careful around ducks.
Seriously. But it's okay to be smug
with a panda.
If you've got extra time carve Lincoln
out of Oreo filling.
Or check out more of Sam
Spratt's work. He recently made some
awesome mean faces.
Forever alone is good too. It's also good
as a costume. If you can't afford
costumes, here's how to be a table.
It really, I mean, it's safer than trying
to sit with a dog around.
But let's move on to a famous photo.
This Windows desktop image
has a title. It's called "Bliss" and was
taken in 1996 by a man named
Charles O'Rear in Sonoma County, California.
Now, since the photo was taken
a vineyard has moved in and today
the hill looks like
this. Let's get mappy. This map shows what
people call soft drinks.
Blue is where they say 'pop,'
yellow is where they say 'soda'
and red is where they tend to call all soft drinks
'coke.' Now this map bloats up and squeezes
countries based on the size
of their annual GDP, the total market
value of all goods and services the
country produces in a year.
Notice how small the African continent
is, even though it's actually
quite large.
Seriously, you could fit
United States inside Africa along with
Europe, India,
China, Japan and more.
By the way,
the diameter of the Moon is
approximately the length
of the United States of America,
which means that roughly, to scale,
this is the size of the Moon.
And finally,
this map shows the remoteness of areas of the world.
The darker the region,
the further away it is from a large city.
But if you really wanna get away,
climb to the top of Chimborazo in
Ecuador.
It's not the tallest mountain in the
world, but because the Earth
bulges slightly in the middle and it's
a big mountain near the equator,
its peak is actually the furthest point on
Earth from the center of the Earth.
Now, a bunch of dogs
shaking off water.
Enjoy.
Okay, here's a trick. If you wanna know
where an image came from or find other
versions or sizes,
go to Google Image Search and drag the picture
right into your browser.
Boom. Success.
And if you wanna lose your mind,
there are plenty of GIFs to do it,
but I'll recommend ScillyMission's Swirl page.
Move your cursor around and feel powerful or
nauseous.
Of course, the best cure for nausea is
eating a baby. Right, grandma? Oh boy.
Instead, let's just wear slippers
shaped like babies. And here's something
huge. In our explosion video I mentioned
the US's Pacific atomic tests
and then yesterday I came across this
incredible real photo of the beach
and in the distance an atomic underwater detonation.
It's pretty terrifying.
Just a few hours ago
Vsauce surpassed 300,000 subscribers,
which is awesome.
You guys rule and
the Vsauce team will continue to bring
you exactly what you want,
because...
As always,
thanks for watching.